TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING AND
WELCOME TO HEARING OF THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
IN RESPONSE TO THE COVE IN
NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO PROTECT
THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WHO MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
WE'RE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE CAPITOL AND
THERE ARE NO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW AND WE WILL
BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PARK
RIDE PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AGAIN THAT'S.
877-226-8152 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS THREE THREE FOUR ONE
SIX SEVEN- I'LL SAY THAT AGAIN
THE ACCESS CODE IS THREE THREE
FOUR. ONE SIX SEVEN OO FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO WITH THE SENATE.
ENERGY COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN
WE MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR
TO DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS
ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR THE OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER. THERE
MAY BE A SHORT WAIT PLEASE BE
PATIENT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR
LINE NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE. FOR THE MODERATOR TO
CALL YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT
TIME YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE. YOU ARE WATCHING
THE HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU. AND WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT'S DONE CLEARLY SO TURN OFF
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING US
SO YOU CAN SPEAK. AND OBVIOUSLY
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN YOUR PATIENTS.
ARE MAINTAINED DECORUM AS IS
CUSTOMARY FOR HEARINGAND ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. IT'S ALSO A
GOOD TIME TO REMIND EVERYBODY
PROVIDING TESTIMONY THAT THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. SO
PLEASE LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO
THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL. YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON AND
REFRAIN FROM REPEATING PRIOR
TESTIMONY OR RE LITIGATING THE
POLICY MERITS OF THE BILL THIS
IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE. WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE HEARING PROCESS AND
THE CONDUCTOR HEARINGS IN THIS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MATTERS
CUSTOMARY.THERE MAY BE SOME
TIME THERE MAY BE SOME LAG TIME
FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO ARE
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TOOLS AND TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT SO ALL INTERESTED
PARTIES CAN HAVE THEIR VOICES
HEARD. TODAY'S HEARINGS WILL BE
SHORT AND WE HAVE ONLY. ONE
URGENCY MEASURE ON THE AGENDA.
BEFORE WE HAD A PRESENTATION.
FROM MISTER. IS BUILT. WHAT
ESTABLISH A- SO MISTER CHIEF.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
FORTINO I'M HERE. SENATOR BATES
HERE. HERE SORRY CENTER FORTINO
HERE SENATOR BATES HERE CENTER
BRADFORD YEAH. PERCENT OF
BRADFORD HERE SENATOR JONES.
JONES HERE SENATOR COM LONGER
HERE. ANOTHER HERE CENTER
LAYERED HERE. LAYERED HERE
CENTER. LIKE OWSKI HERE HERE.
SEVEN MEMBERS WE HAVE A CAR SO
WILL MOVE TO THE BIZ OF THE- R.
FOR BILL AND ALL BILL IS AB ONE
OH FIVE. BY SIMPLY GONZALES
WHICH IS ON PEOPLE INSTRUCTION
RETENTION GREAT CHANGE AND
EXEMPTIONS THIS IS THE ONE AND
ONLY ITEM AS I SAID IT'S AN
EMERGENCY MEASURE MS GONZALEZ
WELCOME AND PLEASE TELL US
ABOUT YOUR BILL. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I DON'T THINK I NEED TO
TELL ANYONE IN THIS CHAMBER HOW
TOUGH THE PANDEMIC WAS ON
STUDENTS AND THEIR PARENTS. AT
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES HAVE
FACED A SCHOOL YOU'RE LIKE NO
OTHER COUNTLESS STUDENTS HAVE
COMPLETELY DISENGAGED FROM
SCHOOL IN THE CHALLENGES ARE
UNIQUE PER STUDENT AND FAMILY.
AND WE HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO
HELP AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE EIGHTY
ONE OH FOUR WOULD EMPOWER
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES WITH A
VARIETY OF CHOICES AT HOLD
STUDENTS HARMLESS INCLUDING THE
BILL ABILITY TO PATIENT
PETITION FOR GRADE RETENTION.
PURSUE CREDIT RECOVERY
OPPORTUNITIES BEYOND A FORTY
YEAR HIGH SCHOOL TO ENSURE THE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY GRADUATE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL ITS REQUEST A PASS
NO PASS OPTION FOR GRADES A
CHANGE THIS ACADEMIC YEAR HE B.
ONE OH FOUR IS REALLY ABOUT
CHOICE THE CHOICE OF PARENTS
AND STUDENTS. TO ENSURE THAT
THEY CAN COMPLETE THEIR
EDUCATION TO ENSURE THAT THEY
ARE HELD HARMLESS BY WHAT WAS
IMPOSED UPON THEMAND TO INSURE
THAT JUST BECAUSE THEY COULD
NOT LEARN REMOTELY IN THE SAME
MANNER THAT THEY DID WHEN THEY
WERE IN PERSON. THAT THEY'RE
NOT PREVENTED FROM GOING TO
COLLEGE. OUR BUDGET THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT OF PROVIDING
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL SUPPORTS
TO SCHOOLS RIGHT NOW BUT THE
COST TO SCHOOLS FROM THIS BILL
WILL BE. FOR WILL FAR EXCEED.
WE'LL BE XC BY THE VALUE I'M
SORRY. PROVIDED TO STUDENTS WHO
STRUGGLED THIS PAST YEAR NO
MATTER HOW WE LOOK AT IT WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE ALL THE TOOLS
POSSIBLE. THESE ARE JUST THREE
BASIC TOOLS THAT ARE STUDENTS
AND PARENTS NEED TO IN ORDER.
TO FILL US THEIR SCHOOL YEARS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THEM ABOUT.
OUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH- SO
LET'S MOVE TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
FOR ANYONE HERE IN THE GALLERY
LET'S SEE OFFICERS AND THE- WE
HAVE NO PRIMARY WITNESSES SO
THERE'S ANYONE IN THE GALLERY
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. SAYING NO ONE UP TOP
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM-
ONE TWELVE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE NOBODY IN
ROOM ONE TWELVE- WILL NOW MOVE
TO ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WITH WE NEED TO TESTIFY. IN
OPTED FOR- IN SUPPORT ON THE
LINE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR IF YOU HAVE ANYBODY
ON THE PHONE LINE. THIS IS
THEIR OPPORTUNITY AND OBVIOUSLY
WE DID NOT HAVE PRIMARY
WITNESSES SO WE'RE IN THE ME
TOO- NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION SO IT'S THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT. FOR A.
B. ONE OH FOUR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF A B. ONE OH FOUR.
PLEASE PRESS ONE TO ZERO. AND
THE OPERATOR WILL PROVIDE YOU
WITH YOUR LINE NUMBER AND PUT
YOU BACK INTO Q. ONCE AGAIN IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
A B. ONE OH FOUR. WEST ONE ZERO
NOW. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
OPPOSED PLEASE RE QUEUE ME. LIE
NUMBER NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME
IS SERRA AGNES KELLY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE OH FOUR THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WE ARE ON SUPPORT
TESTIMONY RIGHT NOW. SO PLEASE
QUEUE UP THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT. OF AB ONE OH FOUR.
THANK YOU MR CHAIR LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ONCE AGAIN IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT AND EIGHTY ONE OH
FOUR. ONE ZERO NOW THAT IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF A B. ONE OH
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
NOW. IT IS TIME TO CHEER WE
HAVE NO WAY Q. ALL RIGHT WE
OFFERED OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT. TESTIMONY WE WILL NOW
GO TO. THE SAME PROCESS FOR
OPPOSITION. AND THERE ARE NO
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES
AND WE'LL GO TO THE GALLERY-
THERE'S NOBODY IN THE GALLERY
AND WE WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE. THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
ONE TWELVE OPPOSED TO AB ONE OH
FOUR SO NOW. MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP WITH THOSE FOLKS ON
THE PHONE LINE WHO WISH TO SAY
THEY OPPOSE. AB ONE OH FOUR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IF YOU'RE USING A SPEAKER
PHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HANDSET ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF. AB
ONE OH FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN THEY'RE ON NOW. IMAGE WE
HAVE FOR PEOPLE TO NOT NOW ONE
MOMENT SIR. SO MY NUMBER
THIRTEEN REMINDER OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIS ACROSS TOWN OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND YOU DID
NOT TAKE TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION AND I'M RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR A FEW MOMENTS TO
SPEAK MY OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL YOU DID NOT HAVE A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION MANAGER
ARE DENTISTS PART OF THE
FINANCE YOU'VE GIVEN IF YOU
WANT I IF YOU COULD IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND SINCE WE DIDN'T HAVE A
PRIMARY WIN THIS. I WILL GIVE
YOU TWENTY SECONDS. YOU
TYPICALLY GET TWO MINUTES WHAT
IS THE DIFFERENCE OF MILLIE
YEAH I'M FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON MAY SEVENTH WE'RE
THRILLED THAT THIS IS GOING TO
COST CALIFORNIANS. HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS DEPENDING
ON THE SIZE OF THE DISTRICT
MANAGER. FROM ONE YOU STILL
HAVEN'T IDENTIFIED YOURSELF
WHICH I'VE ASKED YOU TO DO NOW
RESPECTFULLY. PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF. ONE MOMENT. THIS. ALL
RIGHT FAILING THAT WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT PERSON. POLITE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS HEATHER KELLER FROM
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU HEATHER. BLIND NUMBER
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS
NICOLE YOUNG I'M CALLING FROM
PLASTER COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THIS
IS A BAND AID OVER A BULLET
HOLE THANK YOU. LINE NUMBER
TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS MIKE
MATTINGLY AND- THE ORGANIZATION
CALLED UPON TO FATHERS. AND WE
DO NOT SUPPORT THIS A. B. ONE
OF FOUR OR THE WAY YOU GUYS ARE
HANDLED THANK YOU WHO DID THAT
AGAIN WHAT YOU GUYS HAVE TO
STAY IT'S AN OUTRAGEOUS YOU'RE
HANGING UP ON PEOPLE. THANK YOU
LINE NUMBER TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS SUZANNE ORTEGA I'M
IN LA COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL I BELIEVE IS
UNNECESSARY- RIDICULOUS AND-
EXCEPT THE SPENDING THE AREA
THANK YOU. LIE NUMBER NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NAME IS SARAH AND
NATALIE AND FROM RIVERSIDE
COUNTY I STRONGLY OPPOSE AB.
ONE OH FOUR. AND AT THIS TIME
IF THE CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE THANK YOU ALL RIGHT HAVING
HEARD FROM THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. TO AB
ONE OH FOUR WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHICH HAS A FILE ON THIS BILL.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SHOWING UNDER
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. I'M
HAPPY TO BE HERE THIS MORNING-
WELL RECOGNIZING THE URGENT
NEED TO SUPPORT STUDENTS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC- WE
CURRENTLY ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL IS TO CREATE SIGNIFICANT
COST. LOCAL COSTS AND POTENTIAL
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE AN
ESTIMATED IN THE MILLIONS TO
LIVE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE STILL. WE NOTE MANY ELEAZAR
OF ADOPTED POLICIES MANDATED BY
THIS BILL IN ADDITION TO OTHER
INNOVATIVE STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC
AND IMPROVE STUDENT GRADUATION
RATES. ADDITIONALLY THE STATE'S
ACCOUNTABILITY SYSTEM. THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DASHBOARD
AND LOCAL CONTROL AND
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN REQUIRES
SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO ROUTINELY
EXAMINER LOCAL GRADUATION
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE STUDENTS
ARE SUPPORTED AND ABLE TO
GRADUATE ON TIME. THANK YOU
THANK YOU HAVING HEARD FROM
FINANCE WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS I
KNOW MISTER WHITE HOUSE YOU
HAVE A QUESTION. CARE FOR
FINANCE. HOW IN THE WORLD CAN
THIS COST HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS- PLEASE SHOW ME. ON
THE ISSUE OF GREAT CHANGES. YOU
KNOW A PARENT AT I MEAN MY WIFE
IS WITH THE TEACHER I'M
FAMILIAR WITH THE FREMONT
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT- SHE'S.
THE ACADEMIC IS INSTRUCT AND
STRUCTURE FOR MATH AND SCIENCE
THERE ARE ALL KINDS OF
CONFERENCES GOING ON BETWEEN
PARENTS AND STUDENTS AND KIDS
AT THE END OF THE SCHOOL YEAR.
TO GET A GREAT. PLEASE EXPLAIN
WHAT THE ACTUAL COST FOR THE
GREAT CHANGES TO STUDENT SAYS
I'M A STUDENT I GOT A C. IN
BIOLOGY CAN YOU JUST. CHANGE IT
TO A PASS WHAT IS THE COST OF
THAT IN THE NEXT THREE WEEKS.
AND WHAT'S YOUR CELL NUMBER
UNDER HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS. HI SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION SO WE'VE
BROKEN UP THE NIGHT INTO TWO
PIECES AT THE FIRST PIECE- IS
REGARDING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
RETENTION POLICY AND THE
CONSULTATIONS AND FOR THAT WE
DO HAVE A RANGE FROM AS LOW AS
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER ELLIE
EIGHT DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF
THE NBA. FOR THE OTHER CIVIC TO
ELLIE IS THAT SERVE NINE
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADERS- THE
COST ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THAT
ARE MANDATED ARE DEPOSED AND
IMPLEMENT THE NEW POLICIES
AROUND GREAT CHANGES AS WELL AS
TO PROVIDE EXPANDEDACADEMIC
OPPORTUNITIES TO STUDENTS NOT
ON TRACK TO GRADUATE IN A
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO TWENTY
TWENTY TWO SCHOOL YEARS AND
THOSE COSTS WE ESTIMATE COULD
RANGE ANYWHERE FROM FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS REALLY EIGHT
TO FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TRILLION OR MORE. AND
THEY GET THAT DEPENDS ON THE
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE PROVIDED
TO THE STUDENTS AND THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS UTILIZING THEM SO
THERE IS A BROAD RANGE OF
POTENTIAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THOSE PROVISIONS THAT ARE.
MANDATED IN A BILL THANK YOU IS
SICK IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING WITH
THE AVERAGE DAILY ATTENDANCE IF
THE DECISION IS MADE TO RETAIN
THAT TRIAL THAT THAT AT THE
GRADE LEVEL WHATEVER LEVEL OF
MOVIE THEY STILL GET THE MONEY
FOR THE. ATTENDANCE OF THE
CHILD IN THE COMING YEAR. WE
THAT A IF THERE ARE MORE
STUDENTS. BUT LET'S SAY WE
DON'T GRAD. X. NUMBER WE HAVE
X. MINUS WHATEVER THAT THE
VARIABLE IS WOULDN'T THEY
RECEIVE THAT MONEY DURING THE
SCHOOL YEAR TO PAY FOR THAT.
THAT THE SERVICES. YOU'RE IN
YOU'RE SAYING IT'S GOING TO
COST MAYBE A SCHOOL DISTRICT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS JUST
TO MAKE THAT EVALUATION. AND
CHANGE THE REGULATIONS. SENATOR
I THINK THE COST TO BE
DEPENDENT ON AGAIN THE NUMBER
OF STUDENTS THAT THIS WOULD
IMPACT WHICH IS WHICH IS THAT.
AND THEN THE LEVEL OF DETENTION
OF SERVICES OR- EDUCATIONAL
ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
PROVIDED TO THAT STUDENT. OR
GROUP OF STUDENTS WHICH WOULD
PROBABLY VERY AND BE TAILORED
TO THAT STUDENT- WHICH COULD. I
THINK THE BILLS DESCRIBES IT AS
NO UP COULD COULD INCLUDE-
ADDITIONAL SUMMER CLASSES OF
CREDIT. BY JUST A HOST OF
DIFFERENT- OPPORTUNITIES- AND
BECAUSE THE BILL REQUIRES THOSE.
OUR CONCERN IS WITH THE
POTENTIAL MANDATE ON ELLIE ACE
IRRESPECTIVE OF YOU KNOW THE
FUNDING THAT IS PROVIDED TO
LIAISE WHETHER IT BE STATE OR
FEDERAL MONIES AT THE FACT THAT
WE'RE MANDATING IT. IN THIS IN
THIS MEASURE WOULD NOT PRECLUDE
PRECLUDE LEDS FROM FILING A
MANDATE FOR REIMBURSEMENT WITH
THE COMMISSION ON STATE
MANDATES WOOL OKAY FINANCE THAT
SAYS THEY'RE MANDATING IT BUT
IF WE DID NOTHING WE KNOW THAT
AFTER FIFTEEN YEARS FIFTEEN
MONTHS IN DISTANT LEARNING THAT
SOME MANY IT'S WELL PUBLICIZED
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE NOT
LIVING IN A VACUUM THAT THE
THESE KIDS ARE NOT SHOWING UP
OR THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT GETTING.
GETTING THERE YOU MEAN YOU MUST
HAVE SEEN THIS COMING THAT
THERE COULD BE THIS DECISION
NOW THAT IT'S JUNE AND THE
REPORT CARDS OR DO THAT
SOMETHING NEEDED TO BE DONE AND
THAT AND THAT THESE EACH AND
EVERYONE OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAD SOME IDEA OF WHO
THE NO SHOWS ON THE ON IT WITH
THE KIDS THIS SHOULDN'T BE A
SURPRISE- ON THE IMPACT THAT
TAPPING IT THIS IS A LIFE LINE
NIGHT IS I READ IT. TO SAY OKAY
HERE'S A PROCEDURE TO GO
THROUGHTHE WITH THE GRADES AND
BE VERY FLEXIBLE ABOUT THE
RETENTION AND THEN DO WHAT'S IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE CHILD
I MEAN IF. WE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING THEY WOULD JUST. THEY
HAVE TO DO SOME ANYWAY BUT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD HAVE TO
MAKE THIS IS WHETHER THE KITTEN.
GRADE OR PROMOTE THEM FIFTH. WE
WOULDN'T BE DIZZY. WHEN HE SAID
YOU HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT DID OUR
THAT WERE EXPECTED TO COME.
BECAUSE THEY HAD THEY WOULD
HAVE DONE SOMETHING WITH IF WE
WEREN'T HERE RIGHT NOW THE-EVERYONE AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S DOING SOMETHING. I
JUST WANNA BE SURE THAT YOUR
NUMBER. IS THE ADDITIONAL COST
BECAUSE IT WOULD HAVE. WELL DO
IT. THEY COULD HAVE DONE. IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE THING THAT THEY
WOULD JUST DO NOTHING BUT
YOU'RE YOU'RE STICKING WITH A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
EXTRA TO DO THE WORK THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE HAD TO DO ANYWAY. OR
DECISIONS THEY HAD TO MAKE
ANYWAY. SARA YES IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS YOUR FIRST YOUR FIRST
ISSUE ON ON WHETHER OR NOT WE
SAW THIS COMING- AS YOU KNOW-
BACK IN FEBRUARY- THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AND GOVERNOR
DID SIGN EIGHTY EIGHTY SIX
WHICH PROVIDED FOUR POINT SIX
BILLION AND ONETIME PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT ARE EXPECTED
LEARNING- TO ADDRESS MANY MANY
OF THE CONCERNS THAT ARE.
INCLUDED IN THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL- WOULD SAY THAT AGAIN
BECAUSE THE BILL. ON ITS ON ITS
OWN AS A STATUTORY FRAMEWORK IS
MANDATING. THESE REQUIREMENTS
ON L. A.'S SO AGAIN WOULD NOT
PRECLUDE THE ALLEY ACE FROM
FROM FILING A MANDATE FOR
REIMBURSEMENT FOR THESE
REQUIREMENTS AS SET FORTH IN
THE MAIL. I GUESS THAT THE
PUBLIC SHOULD KNOW THAT THIS AB
EIGHTY SIX THAT WE PASSD
EARLIER THIS YEAR IS FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION. FOR THE ALLEY ACE
TO SUPPORT THE STUDENTS THAT
WAS ONE OF THE CHALLENGE THAT
WE GAVE WE GAVE EXAMPLES OF
WHAT THE TO DO WITH THIS IN MY
MIND. THEY SHOULD BE PATIENT
EVERYBODY SHOULD HAVE SEEN THIS
COMING AND I'LL MAKE A MOTION
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
APPROVE IT MR CHERRY PREFIGURE
INTELLIGENCE. THANK YOU- MISS
UNDETERRED YOU WON'T HAVE ANY
FINAL THOUGHTS COMMENT. THANK
YOU CHAIR YOU'RE GOOD ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MR
JONES. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
JUST WANTED TO FIND OUT WITH
THIS SCHOOL YEAR ENDING. AND
THE SCHOOLS GOING ON BREAK HOW
DO YOU ENVISION. THE TEACHERS
INTERACTING WITH THE PARENTS
AND- GOING TO THIS CONVERSATION.
WELL THIS BILL HAS BEEN IN
PROCESS IN FACT- ALL OF IN
FEBRUARY ALL OF THE- AB EIGHTY
SIX CAME OUT OF A B. ONE OH
FOUR IN ORDER TO DO THE FINDING
PEACE. BUT WE ARE AT THAT
MOMENT WHEN- THIS HAS TO PASS
IF WE EXPECT THESE KINDS OF
CONVERSATIONS TO BE HAD THE
PROBLEM RIGHT NOW AND I CAN'T
SAY EXACTLY HOW IT WOULD HAPPEN
BUT THE PROBLEM RIGHT NOW IS.
AN AND SOME PARENTS ARE THIS
AND UNFORTUNATELY- CENTER WHITE
HOUSE SKI THE TRUTH IS SOME
DISTRICTS AREN'T GOING TO DO
ANYTHING THERE ARE NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS BECAUSE OF THEIR
POLICY THAT IF YOU ASK THEM
LOOK MY CHILD WAS NEVER ON ZOOM
OR THE ZOOM WAS OFTEN THEY'RE
RUNNING AROUND THE HOUSE I KNOW
THAT THEY LOST A FULL YEAR OF
INSTRUCTION THE SCHOOL WILL
TELL YOU IT IS OUR POLICY. TO
NOT- COULD DO SOCIAL PROMOTION
RIGHT WE HAVE A POLICY AN
ABSOLUTE. POLICY CAN'T EVEN
TALK TO US ABOUT RETENTION. WE
CAN EVEN HAVE THAT KIND. NOW SO
YES THEY WOULD HAVE TO MAKE
THEMSELVES AVAILABLE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THE TEACHER
BY THE WAY THIS CONVERSATION
SHOULD BE HAPPENING. WE SHOULD
HAVE TO MANDATE THESE
CONVERSATIONS UNFORTUNATELY
THERE ARE SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN SOME SCHOOLS. THAT JUST HAVE
A BRIGHT LINE SAY WE'LL TAKE
CARE OF IT DON'T WORRY YOU GUYS
GO UP IN SACRAMENTO AND SEND US
MONEY. AND WE'LL FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DO IT. WE JUST WANT TO GIVE
PARENTS THE OPPORTUNITY THAT
THEY HAVE. TO ACTUALLY CALL THE
SCHOOL AND TALK TO SOMEBODY
STARTING WITH THE PRINCIPAL AND
FIGURING OUT HOW TO TALK TO THE
TEACHER. AND FIGURE OUT THE
BEST PATH FORWARD SOME SCHOOLS
LIKE IN IN- IMPACTED IN OUR
SHARED AREA. IF YOU WELL NOT
EXACTLY SHARED BUT IT'S A NEW
COUNTY. START SCHOOL AS EARLY
AS JULY- RIGHT- AND SO YOU KNOW
THAT CONVERSATION MAYBE IN THE
BEGINNING HERE WE MAY HAVE SOME
ADJUSTMENT PERIOD BUT IT'S A
CONVERSATION THAT HAS TO
HAPPEN. AND BY THE WAY WE'RE
WORKING IN THE SCHOOL YEAR AND
THEIR SENIORS WERE NOT
GRADUATING AND DON'T REALIZE
THAT THEY COULD STAY AN EXTRA
YEAR. FOR PORTIONS OF THE YEAR
IN ORDER TO GET THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN GRADUATE WITH A HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND FINISHING A
G. E. D. IS EXTREME. AND SO
THESE ARE THINGS THAT YES WE
SHOULD HAVE DONE IT WAY BACK IN
FEBRUARY HAVE AN URGENCY
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO
GET IT THROUGH BUT WE NEED TO
PROVIDE. OPPORTUNITIES AND
CHOICES FOR PARENTS AND
STUDENTS- TO HAVE HAVE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. SO THERE'S NOTHING
IN YOUR BILL THAT. YOUR BILL IS
SILENT TOO. IF THE SCHOOLS ON
BREAK AND THE TEACHERS ON
BREAK- M. INNER. YOU CAN.
TEACHER BECOME. TO COME BACK.
DOWN THIS KIND. OR I I'M I'M IN.
TO ARE GONNA WANT TO HAVE KIND.
SO THERE. BUT THERE'S GOING TO
BE OUTLYING SITUATIONS WHERE
TEACHERS I'M ON BREAK I'M NOT
AVAILABLE. HOW TO USE. IT A
BILL I THINK IS SILENT AS I
TRACK IT IS THE ONLY PROBABLY
BE CONDITIONAL COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AND- I ASSUME AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL HOWEVER THE
CONVERSATION HAS TO TAKE PLACE
RIGHT. AND THAT'S THE POINT
WE'RE TRYING TO PUSH IN A LOT
OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
STARTED. TALKING ABOUT THIS KID
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE BILL IS
COMING IN AND WE THINK THAT'S A
POSITIVE THING. EVEN IF THE
CONVERSATION TAKES PLACE RIGHT
WHEN- SCHOOL STARTS AGAIN. WITH
THAT TEACHER RIGHT WHEN THEY
COME BACK A FEW WEEKS BEFORE
SCHOOL THERE'S NOTHING TO
PREVENT. THAT THAT TEACHER. THE
ADMINISTRATOR AT THE PARENT
DECIDING THE SCHOOL THE- CHILD
SHOULD START BACK IN FIRST
GRADE AND UP. ME ONE SECOND
GRADE WELL I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT
UP THE POINT ON SOME OF THESE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS BEING. EIGHTY
EIGHT NOT WANTING AT ALL TO
HAVE THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
RETENTION AND. I THINK- MEET
MAYBE INTENTION OR ANY. USED IN
A POOR. NERVE THERE THAT I
WOULD LOVE TO CAN. TO COME. ON
THIS MAY BE SURPRISING TO
SEVERAL PEOPLE HERE BUT I WAS
HELD BACK. IN THE THIRD GRADE-
I'M BORN I WAS BORN IN AUGUST-
SO FROM KINDERGARTEN THROUGH
THIRD GRADE I WAS THE I. I WAS
ALWAYS BEHIND- WE I THINK IT'S
INCUMBENT UPON US AS LEADERS IN
CALIFORNIA THAT OUR VALUE
EDUCATION. FOR SOME REASON
THERE'S BECOME A STIGMA. AND
PARENTS EGOS GET IN THOUGH AND
I'VE HAD THE SAME I'VE HAD THIS
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE WITH
FRIENDS OF MINE THAT HAVE
REFUSED TO HOLD THEIR KIDS
BACK- BECAUSE THEY TOOK IT AS A
STIGMA OR A- THEY FAILED OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT THE U. TWO
PARENTS DON'T FAIL. WHEN THEIR
KIDS NEED TO BE HELD BACK THE
KIDS JUST NOT READY TO GO TO
MOVE ON AND THAT HAPPENS- IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT MALCOLM
GLADWELL WROTE A BOOK CALLED
THE OUTLIERS THE STORY OF
SUCCESS. IN PART ONE OF THE
STUDIES IN THAT BOOK IS HE
LOOKED AT WHAT MADE- IS CERTAIN
CANADIAN YOUTH HOCKEY TEAMS
MORE SUCCESSFUL OR PLAYERS MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN OTHER. YOUTH
HOCKEY PLAYERS AND WHAT HE
FOUND OUT WAS THE KIDS THAT WE
WENT INTO KINDERGARTEN AT A
LATER AGE. ACTUALLY ARE THE-ONES THAT EXCELLED AND BECAME
THE BETTER PLAYERS. WHICH WHEN
YOU LOOK AT LIKE. YOU DON'T
THINK OF THIS BUT SOON AS IT'S
OUT IN THE BOOK IT MAKES
PERFECT SENSE THESE KIDS ARE
SIX MONTHS TO TWELVE MONTHS
YEARS- TWELVE MONTHS OLDER THAN
THE OTHER KIDS OF COURSE ARE
GOING TO EXCEL. AND DO BETTER
SO- YOU KNOW MAYBE. WE NEED TO
BE ALSO IN ADDITION TO THIS AND
I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY-
IN ADDITION TO THIS WE MAYBE
NEED TO BE LOOKING AT SOME
POLICY ISSUES NEXT YEAR. WITH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT. HAVE
THAT ATTITUDE THAT I THINK WE
NEED TO START DRESSING AND
REMOVING THE STIGMA OF CHILDREN
BEING HELD BACK. SOMETIMES
THAT'S THE VERY BEST THING THAT
CAN HAPPEN TO HIM. FOR ME- I
DID THIRD GRADE TWICE WHEN I
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL I
WAS IN THE TOP 10% OF MY CLASS.
WENT ON IMMEDIATELY TO COLLEGE.
AND THAT WOULD NOT HAVE
HAPPENED IF I HAD NOT BEEN HELD
BACK SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT.
SHOULD THE CHAIR AND THE
AUTHORS INDULGENCE. ON THE-
POLICY DISCUSSION THANK YOU. WE
HAVE HAD A ROBUST CONVERSATION
TODAY I SEE NO OTHER HANDS
WHAT. WE FELT MS CALM WATER.
STARTED INTO YOUR HANDS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR I HAVE A
QUESTION I THINK FOR BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE FIRST QUESTION SORT
OF BUILDING ON WHAT. FROM THE
SENATOR FROM FREMONT WAS.
RAINING ON IS THE ESTIMATE OF
THE HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS IS
THAT BASED ON. THE ASSUMPTION
THAT EVERY CHILD IN THE SYSTEM.
WE'LL BE USING THE SUPPORT. AND
WHERE IS THE ESTIMATE COMING
FROM. HI SENATOR THIS IS JULIE
ON AIR WITH APARTMENT FINANCE
FOR THE S. MI. RANGE BASED ON
EACH OF THE LEDS PARTIES. HELLO
MY M. I NEEDED NO. WE CAN HEAR
YOU I HEAR YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
AT IT'S A HIGH LEVEL ESTIMATE
BASED ON EACH ELLIE A
PARTICIPATING IN EACH OF THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL
STARTING FROM A LOW RANGE FOR
AN ALLEY A. FOR THE FIRST
PORTION OF THE BILL REGARDING-
THE RETENTION ISSUE OF A LOW
FIVE HUNDRED. SMALLEY ELLIE
EIGHT TO. FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS- FOR A LARGER LED AND
THE SAME THING FOR THE SECOND
PART OF THE BILL REGARDING A
GREAT CHANGES IN PROVIDING
EXPANDED ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITIES
TO STUDENTS IT'S AT THE ALLEY A
LEVEL- RANGING FROM A LOW OF
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS- TWO FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. I
DON'T HAVE MORE GRANULARITY
THAN THAT THEN IT'S BASED ON-
BATTLE AND FOR THE SECOND WHERE
THERE IS A MUCH WIDER RANGE OF
COSTS FROM FIVE THOUSAND TO
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND FOR VERY
LARGE L. EA- IT IS IT HAS BEEN
REDUCED FOR NOT ALL LEDS
BECAUSE NOT ALL AT LEAST SERVE
NINE THREE TWELFTH GRADERS SO
THAT HAS BEEN REDUCED TO ABOUT
ONE THIRD OF. THE TOTAL NUMBER
OF LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES.
SO IT'S BASED ON THE SIZE OF
THE ALLEY A NOT NECESSARILY THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS. AND I WOULD
ADD IT. YOU KNOW IT'S AN
ESTIMATED RANGE AND IT IS
UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME HOW MANY
STUDENTS YOU KNOW WOULD BE
UTILIZING- ADDITIONAL SERVICES
AND WHAT THOSE SERVICES WOULD
BE. DEPENDENT ON THE L. OKAY
AND THEN FOR CLARIFICATION.
IT'S FOR. IS IT I READ IT FOUR
HI FOLKS KIDS ARE IN HIGH
SCHOOL BUT IT'S FOR EVERY
STUDENT THAT HAPPEN TO BE
ENROLLED. IN CLASS DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SCHOOL YEAR.
RETENTION THREE TENSION
QUESTION FOR ME OR FOR THE ODD
FUNNELED INTO THE OFFICE AND
THE RETENTION PIECE IS ALL
GRADES THE ADDITIONAL YEAR TO
GRADUATE IS FOR OBVIOUSLY
ELEVENTH AND TWELFTH GRADERS
AND THEY PASS NO PASS IS NINE
THREE TWELVE GRADES UP DEFECTOR
COLLEGE ADMISSIONS OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU THAT WAS HELPFUL. AND
THEN YOU KNOW- DEPARTMENT OF
ANY THE- THIS PART OF THE CORE
I WAS ASKING YOU KNOW THE FIRST
PART WAS ABOUT SORT OF THE
ESTIMATE BUT MY ASSUMPTION IS
THAT REGARDLESS OF IF THEIR
DISTRICTS THAT ARE- MAKING
THESE KINDS OF SUPPORTS
AVAILABLE THAT ALL DISTRICTS
STILL HAVE SYSTEMS IN PLACE ON
INFRASTRUCTURE COULD YOU COULD
HAVE AN INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE
AND YOU'RE JUST DECIDING THAT
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO. ACTIVATE
IT- SO IS THIS SORT OF TAKING
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION OR IS
THIS OUR ESTIMATES ALSO SORT OF
PREDICATED ON THE FACT THAT
SOME ELITE LIAISE DON'T HAVE
ANY OF THIS. THE SUPPORTS IN
PLACE AT ALL- AND HAVE TO BUILD
THAT IN. SENATOR I'D HAVE TO
GET BACK TO YOU ON ON THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL OF THE
ESTIMATE. IF THAT'S OKAY OKAY
BECAUSE I MEAN YOU KNOW THE
REALITY IS WHILE WE DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY STUDENTS WOULD BE
USING THIS WE CERTAINLY KNOW.
THAT TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS DIDN'T CHECK IN AT
ALL- AND I THINK THAT'S THE
THING THAT'S MOST CONCERNING TO
SO MANY OF US THOSE THAT ARE
PARENTS WHO HAVE KIDS THAT ARE
GOING TO SCHOOL. AND THOSE THAT
ACTUALLY CARE ABOUT OUR YOUNG
FOLKS GETTING THE EDUCATION
THAT THEY RIGHTLY DESERVE FROM
THIS STATE- SO. YEAH I WOULD BE
GREAT IF YOU COULD GET BACK TO
US ON THOSE QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED-
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I JUST
WANT TO SAY TWO THINGS ONE IS
IT. JUST SEEMS TO ME THAT THE
FINANCE PROJECTIONS ARE
COMPLETELY UNREALISTIC AND I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO PUT
THAT ON THE RECORD SHOW THAT
WHEN WE TALK TO SPILL OUT.
NOBODY READS THAT- AS AN
AGREEMENT IN JUST HOW OVERBLOWN
THOSE WERE. THE SECOND THING IS
IN READING ANALYSIS ONE THING
PUSH MY BUTTONS A LITTLE I FEEL
THE NEED TO SAY IT. THAT SET UP
ARE YOU GOT A COLLEGE DEGREE
WITHOUT GRADES- YOU KNOW DID
NOT GET A LETTER GRADE WAS NOT
REDUCED TO A NUMBER AND NOTHING
MADE ME CRAZIER THAN PEOPLE
FREAKING OUT SAYING OH MY GOD
THEY DON'T HAVE GRADES WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO WE CAN'T
PROCESS THEM. MY COLLEAGUES
WORK FOR THE PRO TEM WERE
LEGISLATORS WERE DOCTORS OR
LAWYERS FOR EVERYTHING ELSE
ENTREPRENEURS VERY SUCCESSFUL
AND WE WEREN'T REDUCED TO GRADE
SO FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE FREAKING
OUT BECAUSE GRADES ON SHOW UP
THEY JUST NEED TO GET OVER IT
ALL HAPPEN. WOULD BE AN IPHONE.
OUR WE HAVE HAD A- CONVERSE- MS
GONZALEZ WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSE I WOULD AND- I APOLOGIZE
I'M NOT AN EDUCATIONAL EXPERT
I'M JUST A PARENT WHO HAPPENS
TO HAVE STAYED HOME LAST YEAR
WITH THREE KIDS. AND SEEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT NOT ONLY THEY
HAD PUT THEIR FRIENDS HAD
DURING THIS PAST YEAR AND
THAT'S NINETEEN COUNTS BUT GOD
KNOWS HOW MANY PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT WHO NEVER EVEN TURNED
ON A COMPUTER MAYBE THEY DIDN'T
HAVE IT MAYBE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A CONNECTIVITY MAYBE THEY WERE
WORKING BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS
COULDN'T. THIS IS A TIME OF
JUST UNFORESEEN- CIRCUMSTANCES
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND ALTHOUGH I
APPRECIATE- MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO WE SHOULD HAVE A
LARGER DISCUSSION I AGREE WITH
YOU ON THAT BUT THAT'S NOT THE
DISCUSSION HERE THIS IS JUST
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO HAVE THESE
DISCUSSIONS. AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. WE ALLOCATED FOUR POINT
SIX BILLION DOLLARS TO EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX FOR THESE VERY
SUPPORTS THE REQUIRED TO HAVE
THESE VERY SUPPORTS FOR OUR
KIDS. DO WE THINK THAT THAT
THAT. THAT THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
INSTANTLY THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
MORE MONEY FOR SUPPORT BUT
THESE ARE JUST THE SUPPORTS WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW
INSURED THE KIDS ARE ACTUALLY
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL SO
THEY GET THAT DIPLOMA AND THEY
DON'T GET A GED. ENSURING THAT
KIDS ARE. YOU KNOW NOT LOSING
FIRST OR SECOND GRADE LOSING
FIRST GRADE WE KNOW WE KNOW
WHAT HAPPENS IN SECOND GRADE IF
YOU'RE NOT IN THE SECOND GRADE
READING LEVEL WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT ALL THE TIME- WE CERTAINLY
GONNA PRETEND. THAT THAT
DOESN'T MATTER. WE OWE IT TO
OUR CHILDREN AND TO OUR-
PARENTS IT REALLY TORE TEACHERS
AS WELL. TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PUT KIDS IN THE BEST
POSSIBLE SITUATION. AND MY
HEART GOES OUT HAVING JUST GONE
THROUGH THE- THECOLLEGE
PROCESS WITH MY EIGHTEEN YEAR
OLD YOU KNOW. YOU JUST COULDN'T
LEARN. LIKE LET'S SAY YOU WERE
STRAIGHT A STUDENT JUST
COULDN'T LEARN FOREIGN
LANGUAGE. BY ZOOM WELL SUDDENLY
YOU CAN'T GET INTO IT AND
EVERYBODY KNOWS FROM THE
COLLEGES TO UC OR CSU BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW YOU'VE GOT ONE BAD
MARK ON YOUR ON YOUR REPORT
CARD. WHEN IT COULD JUST BE A
PASS NOT BE CONSIDERED IN YOUR
GPA WE HAVE TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT BECAUSE TIMES ARE
DIFFERENT. AND SO I APPRECIATE
ALL THE COMMENTS HERE- I
APPRECIATE THAT. THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE CLEARLY DOESN'T LIKE
THE BILL BUT I THINK WE OWE IT
TO ALL OF OUR CONSTITUENTS TO
PASS IT SO. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NIGHT. THANK YOU FOR THAT
PASSIONATE CLOSE MISTER WHITE
HOUSE GIVE YOU WANT TO MAKE THE
MOST. TO MOVE. WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MISTER CASKEY THE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO PASS. AND.
REFERRED THE BILL TO THE SENATE
FLOOR. MR CONSULTANT CALL THE
ROLL. FIRST BILL ONE OH FOUR
THE MOTION IS TO PAY TO THE SEA
FLOOR SENATOR FORTY I FOR ON
BAYH HI BATES- ICE BRAD ART
SPREAD FIVE SENATOR. I JONES I
CENTERED FROM LONGER I FROM I'D
CENTER LAYER HI EARLIER I LIKE
OUT HI CASKEY ARE SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT SEVENTY ON TO
THIS SENATE FLOOR AND SO THANK
YOU PRESENTING TO BILL THANK
YOU EVERYBODY FOR TWO IN THE
TEST TODAY. IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE
TEST THE- PLEA SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE
YOUR COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
ARE IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT
TO INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THE FISHER HEARING RECORDS
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE ALL
THE PARTICIPATION FOR EVERYONE
AND THEIR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION SO WE'VE CONCLUDED
OUR AGENDA TODAY AND THE SENATE.
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS IS
ADJOURNED.